good news out of Michigan we're under
the leadership of Democratic governor
Gretchen Whitmer Michigan has repealed
an insane 1931 abortion ban this is
really wacky stuff
um do the Detroit Free Press reports
Whitmer repeals Michigan's 1931 abortion
ban with the stroke of her pen Governor
Gretchen Whitmer repealed an
unenforceable Michigan law Wednesday
that makes it a felony to administer
most abortions with no exception for
rape or incest now unenforceable
unenforceable is a critical word here
and so the reason to do this is less
about the idea that that law would start
to be enforced right now but the idea
that it could be enforced depending on
what cons continues to happen at the
highest court of the land the Supreme
Court in the United States and this is a
very very good thing
um it is important to understand that
this is only the beginning of what is
certain to be a much longer uh I guess
we would call it Crusade against
abortion that started decades ago with
the passage of Roe v Wade Roe v Wade uh
uh was about ensuring right to an
abortion but it triggered the battle
against abortion from the American right
they had a major success recently when
the Supreme Court did away with Roe v
Wade and we know that it is only the
beginning here is Governor Gretchen
Whitmer officially signing a repeal of
that abortion ban
hi
all right so most of us understand what
it looks like to sign a piece of paper
and here is Gretchen Whitmer actually
saying something about this just ahead
of the signing I don't want
we know that the decision when and
whether or not to Bear a child is most
consequential decision economically that
a family or a woman will make in her
lifetime the government has no business
getting in the way of conversations
between women and their doctors this
should not really be controversial but
it's did send the American right into a
tizzy hurling the term marxistic
Gretchen Whitmer I don't know why I
don't know why getting rid of an insane
law from 1931 makes you a Marxist in
2023 I don't think they know either I
don't think they know what Marxist even
means but that doesn't matter because
what we do see is their passion if you
want to use that word
for making it as difficult as possible
to get an abortion under any
circumstances and anywhere in the United
States and so this is a small step again
at this point this was an unenforceable
1931 law but it is still important to
get these laws off the books and many
states particularly red states have
these retrograde ancient laws on the
books even if they aren't being enforced
right now any one of these that can be
taken off the table in terms of possible
future enforcement should be considered
a win and remember Governor Gretchen
Whitmer easily easily winning
re-election in November despite a
challenge from Trump endorsed Maga
candidate Tudor Dixon who went down in
flames and we can all be very very happy
about that we'll continue following this
fight for just simple medical rights
that's what we're talking about here
we'll take a break make sure you're
subscribed to the YouTube Channel
youtube.com the davidpackman show what a
program we have for you today this one's
good enough that we might actually
record it